alien covenant went through various
changes during its development ranging
from its title being altered from
Paradise Lost to covenant to director
Ridley Scott changing his mind about
whether Elizabeth sure would return to
major scenes in promotional material
that we never saw in the movie you
became a beloved it's Jan here and in
this video I'm going to break down
everything we know so far about what was
deleted and rejected from the final
curse of alien covenant my alien coven
of merchandise giveaway is also running
on this video so be sure to leave a
comment about the movie and subscribe
for a chance to win one of these two
awesome packs of merch and just before
we get stuck in of course there are
spoilers ahead so be aware of that if
you haven't seen the movie yet first
let's take a look at a major scene
nearly four and a half minutes long that
was completely cut from the final movie
Fox actually released a clip of the
scene online and called it the Last
Supper a title which like so much in the
alien prequels has strong religious
connotations the deleted scene is a
really great introduction to the crew of
the Covenant and is set before they go
into cryo sleep so that means it was
meant to appear before the opening scene
on the ship in the final movie follow
the light are you feel Daniel alright
any dizziness nausea fine it's such a
shame that the scene with curse that
there are so many nice little moments
that give some real insight into
individual characters and the dynamics
between the various members of the group
for example you see the differences in
personality and views between Billy
Crudup second-in-command
Aurum and James Franco's captain Branson
and also Danny McBride pilot Tennessee
so how about hearing it is pure majesty
I don't know what you're talking about
kind of spooks me out some big old see
it nothing and you get a real sense of
simmering tensions between Orem and the
others he can be widely I know you can
hear me as drama games always drunk
I believe in tractor beam on top of that
seeing the crews coupled interact with
each other would definitely have helped
me feel a closer connection to their
characters and therefore would have made
me care a bit more about their deaths
when each of them inevitably gets picked
off as the movie progresses I just
wanted to say hey before I said I'm okay
I'm kind of creating I don't know
feeling good I'm spurning up we're gonna
have one more drink before we went into
cryo sleep
who's gonna lead us in our toast said to
any decent [ __ ] not to say hi captain
make sure everyone pays well yeah
you can kill me alright hey Kathleen
back there that happens
no better
is he gone yeah that's party and of
course the scene would also have met
that James Franco would have got a bit
of real screen time interacting with his
crew instead of just seeing his
characters burnt alive inside a sleeping
pod or rock climbing in a video message
for his wife and yes the scene even
includes a bit of foreshadowing of
captain Branson's fate when he said to
the rest of the crew he's heading off to
cryo sleep early because he's feeling
queasy and burning up there's also a Sun
Easter eggs the original alien chest
bursting seen in what turns out to be a
little fake out by director Ridley Scott
the bit I'm talking about is when comms
experts up Werth he's played by Callie
and Nando's suddenly struggles to
breathe as they're eating which is a
callback to the scene from alien where
John Hurt's character Cain has a similar
reaction during their meal but in hurts
case it's because a chest burster is
about to explode out of him and there's
another nice shout out to that choking
seen an alien when Danny McBride
character Tennessee echos Parker's words
decane the food's not that bad okay down
the wrong pipe I got your back oh that
was a joke break and the deleted scene
finished with a heartfelt and optimistic
speech from Daniel to the crew which
again I think would have enhanced how
the audience related to the covenants
characters so what about that speech - I
have a bomb and excited again Jake asked
me to say something okay please
you
you've all sacrificed so much to be here
to be a part of this it's the first-ever
large-scale colonization mission the
compass far into our galaxy making
history and everyone back on earth who's
really grateful for your hard work and
courage I just want to say I couldn't
pick a better bunch of jerks to get
marooned on a distant planet with so the
continent James Franco's Branson and
Katherine Waterston's Daniels were also
involved and another deleted scene
though this one was set in their New
York apartment the Curt scene would have
set up the backstory in more detail for
why Branson and Daniels wanted to build
a house on the lake when they reached
the remote planet they're about to
journey to although this would have
helped build more of Daniels backstory
given James Franco more time on screen
and afforded us greater insight into
their connection as a couple it seems
like this scene could have felt a bit
too slow right at the beginning of the
movie which is where it would have
appeared so perhaps it was kept the time
and to get the story moving along a bit
more briskly than it would have done if
this scene had been included another
lengthy deleted scene also released
online by Fox features new mirror passes
Elizabeth Shaw and Michael Fassbender's
David in the scene david provides the
voice-over where he explains what
happened at the end of Prometheus and
how he escaped with Elizabeth on an
engineer ship by the way a little piece
of the dialogue from this voice-over is
in the final movie although it's used in
a different scene there are also some
nice moments in this deleted segment
while we get to see the interaction
between Elizabeth and David including
how she took care of him and put him
back together and there's also a hint at
what feels like a bond building between
them after we made contact with the
engineer the Prometheus was destroyed
all hands were lost but I escaped with
Elizabeth in one of their ships I was
badly injured on our mission she put me
back together and never experienced such
compassion certainly not for mr. Weyland
or from any human greens crane back
today
you have to be simple
in fact kind of hot you know
we were able to activate their ship and
set course for their hole we were
finally going to meet our Creator
how long impossible to say what is
forbidden so long as our no worse
stay tight
I'll wake you when we arrive
I also liked how this final sleep tight
that David says to Elizabeth just before
putting her back into cryo sleep his
later mirrored at the end of alien
covenant with the much more menacing
sleep tight don't let the bedbugs bite
that David says to Daniel's the center
into cryo sleep after it finally dawned
on her that he's not Walter I think if
the final film had included these
moments the implied kindness in them
between sure and David would have made
what he did to her later when he used
her body for his genetic experiments
even more horrifying and impactful at
the end of the deleted scene we also get
a hint of why David made the shocking
decision to wipe out the engineers when
he reached their planet after putting
Shore to sleep David wanders in the dark
among the engineers exoskeletons and he
explains how he spent the time on the
journey learning about the engineers
which suggests he discovered something
about them that made him is disappointed
with them as he was with human beings
and this led him to destroy the
engineers when he arrived on their
planet and there are a few other deleted
scenes on board the Covenant the first
shows some footage of Daniel talking to
mother and in another she's playing
cards with Tennessee and it looks like
his wife Ferris might be with him too so
this could be a scene before the crew
land on the planet mother I want a woman
traveling approximately 24 days
there anything for breakfast other than
oatmeal Russians have been selected for
optimal nutritional content
another is bear a planet in the known
universe where full house beats a
strange blue students mother stay out of
this mother and as a cutscene with
Daniel hunting the proto morph that
emerged inside the Covenant where mother
suddenly informs her that it's four
meters above you in fact that bit of the
deleted scene reminded me of the moment
an alien where Lambert's talking to
Dallas while he's in the air ducts and
he suddenly discovers the xenomorph is
upon him so did you enjoy a lien
covenant and were you happy with the
final cut of the movie and were there
any scenes you wish had been kept in the
film or anything you would like to have
seen cut out remember to leave a comment
about the movie and subscribe to your
chance to win one of these awesome alien
Covenant merch packs and hit that
notifications bell to get updated on my
new videos where I'll be announcing the
winners if you liked this video I really
appreciate you hitting the thumbs up
button and while you're here take a look
at my alien covenant Easter Egg video
for more movie deleted scenes by tapping
the links on the screen thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers